hallo liebe leute heute sind wir wieder
auf den straßen von berlin unterwegs
es sind drei grad ist es ein kalter
sonntag und wir schauen heute mal was
die menschen zu dem thema was ist deine
lieblings app oder was machst du mit
deinem handy besonders gerne antworten
werden
los geht's was ist ihre lieblings ab das
ist in norwegisch ihr das wetterbericht
und wie benutzt man die also jeden tag
mehrmals täglich ob es regnet oder
schneit es ist frost
da guckt man einfach wie das wetter ist
vor instagram warum da sieht man bilder
von freunden das immer ganz nett
mein lieblings apps warum weil meine
familie nicht in deutschland wohnt und
ich dann mit denen ständig kommunizieren
kann
liebe leser ich habe einen podcast also
podcast app auch warum nicht also
aufwachen podcast und keine ahnung
den rasen funk die reihe von formaten
fußball podcast ich bin fast 50 jahre
alt und ich habe keine wie viel zeit
verwenden sie sagten zu am handy
trotzdem im handy gar nix gar keine zeit
gar keine zeit guck mal was an das ist
meine mama hat auch schon hand wenn er
keine zeit
instagram zum einkaufen rewe oder so was
machen sie kaufen sie per smartphone bei
rewe
wie geht das naja ich kann die artikel
raussuchen dann gebe ich mein
liefertermin an und dann und die leute
bringen dass sie nach hause und das will
ich auch machen das ist ja toll jetzt
praktisch ja vorliegen wir zwei kindern
das war nicht alles tragen muss es gab
also eine app da kriegst fürs laufen
geld also läuft aus erwarteten ihn dabei
und für jeden schritt den mavs kriegs
und punkte und die punkte kannst du dann
umrechnen lassen und zum beispiel so
google play gutscheine von zehn euro das
ist egal wie heißt die app weist das ist
eine sehr gute frage
ich glaube sogar ich habe das sogar auf
ich kann doch leider mich schon fragen
suite könnte ja ich hab kein smartphone
suite von heißt das hier ist ganz normal
sein wird korrigiert
da geht man drauf ich habe es kein
internet aber naja dann kriegt man die
schritte insgesamt das wird dann so eine
währung ungerecht mäßig welche apps
benutzt du einfach zu unterhaltung so
unterhaltung dann wahrscheinlich youtube
und theater app die arte das ist ein
deutsch französischer sender und da kann
man eben dokumentation auf dem handy
gucken interessant und kaufst du bei
greven mit einer europa gerade erfahren
und ich bin total begeistert
eine kiste bier stand gleich sagen du
lingor tatsächlich auch wenn das
vielleicht die konkurrenz ist aber was
gefällt ihnen daran einfach dass ich im
alltag sprachen dann kam menschen oder
zu hause also meine lieblings app ist
auf jeden fall die podcast app die kennt
ihr bestimmt auch alle da kann man
nämlich zum beispiel so herr bücher
hören wenn man unterwegs ist muss nicht
immer auf dein handy geschaut und es
gibt auch so ja es gibt verschiedene
podcast klar die ich am besten finde und
meine allerliebste pott kanzlerin ist la
martina seiler die finde ich immer
selbst beginnt die macht man so ganz
tolle interviews mit menschen die in dem
buch geschrieben haben oder die
irgendwas tolles auf der welt erschaffen
haben
und ja genau das hat mir meine lieblings
app und jetzt nochmal eine sache vor
zwei monaten haben wir auch angefangen
bei easy german ein podcast zu drehen
und zwar ist es der isi german podcast
und wenn ihr den hören wollt wir
verlinken euch hier unten nochmal den
link zum podcast da könnt ihr euch gerne
mal könnt ihr gerne anklicken und einmal
anhören
[Musik]
was ist ihre lieblings apps facebook
wahrscheinlich oder instagram ja warum
da bin ich am meisten und kann mit
können leuten folgen kann will ich mit
leuten austauschen
jude tatsächlich eine app in der ich
meistens sind studenten oder oder ältere
schüler so aktuelle themen oder so so
erfahrungen teilen sozusagen und ist
ganz lustig aber auch oft sehr sehr
peinlich aber so unterhaltung im traum
gehören das zählt er ist prokrastination
heißt spaß glaube ich ich hatte mal eine
prostitutions erst bei der bäume
gewachsen sind dass man nicht ans handy
gegangen beschreiben
da ich habe cold turkey das ist so
ähnlich das blog man alles da wächst
wachsen keine bäume aber ich benutze
instagram benutze ich ansonsten habe ich
gar nicht so viele apps ich muss mal
kann ich selber gerne die die bee gees
sind so für zwei stunden und die kleinen
so kaktus oder ich weiß nicht so kleine
shops sind wir also für 20 minuten oder
so und wenn man dann trotzdem kommt dann
stirbt alles ich benutze life heißt die
das ist so für frauen wichtig
tatsächlich will unterwegs benutze ich
auch netflix ebay kleinanzeigen habe ich
hier drauf ich habe google calendar habe
ich drauf wenn du whatsapp als er dann
das thema das ist das prima ist ein
schweizer
die ist genauso wie modlos man zahlt 34
euro und die ist angeblich sicherer als
konzept passte posen laden ist
persönlichen daten sicherheit bedeutet
welche apps ich benutze ich
deutschlandfunk euch viel spaß das ist
auch interessant da gibt es ja viel
realismus man sich anschauen kann viel
über berlin youtube k
google maps ist aber auch schon sowieso
darauf regenradar hab ich drauf
regenradar weil sie so eine wetter
wetter genau und eine wasserwaage wasser
muss man haben
klar dass unser video zum thema handy
und co wenn ihr uns noch eine app
empfehlen wollte ihr besonders gerne
benutzt schreibt es doch gerne hier
unten in die kommentare
wenn ihr noch mehr übung zu dieser
episode haben wollt dann werdet doch
einfach ein mitglied von the german denn
dann bekommt ihr interaktive übungen
transkripte und vokalisten wir freuen
uns über jeden daumen hoch von euch also
klickt ihr gerne einmal auf das video
und witte abonniert doch auch gerne den
easy german channel darüber fallen uns
auch natürlich total
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und bis bald
[Musik]